differently absolutely yeah how so well
here's the thing women women want to be
loved a certain way and women uh men
just want to be loved
right so women want to dictate how
they're loved and men just want to be
loved so women are the receivers of love
that's what I this is what I believe and
in turn the woman gives respect back to
the man
however that's not what we're doing
today that's what's messing up the
marketplace so women want to dictate how
they want to be low let me explain that
so I can provide Love to You by
displaying it by demonstrating it I can
support you I can come home to you every
night I can make sure I only have
children with you I can make sure I
don't embarrass you and have other women
out here in their neighborhood I'm not
screwing the whole neighborhood of women
and embarrassing you right I provide for
you
I I bring everything that I do out in
society I I do I do for you
that's love
that would be in the long-term frame a
more survivable form of relationship and
love that guy's displaying it he doesn't
have to express it in words
you don't have to write poetry he's not
going to come home every night I love
you darling
but women want guys to do that
they don't care about the display they
actually say that the displays of Love
they're entitled to that you're supposed
to work for me you're supposed to do
they call it the bare minimum that's a
bare minimum what are you talking about
that's everything
that's how men do we're not expressive
we actually do we I want to show you
when we give you when we when we want to
be endearing to a woman we will gift you
something we'll bring you a rock we'll
shine a rock here you go it's the best I
can do but these people are like give me
your spoil me give me a date here and do
the please so women want to dictate how
they want to be loved and then they find
out that their list is is what we call
5011 uh uh 50 to 11 things long he has
to do this this this this this this this
this this please man nobody's gonna do
that not when you out here fornicating
with everybody you could possibly do it
man [ __ ] man we ain't doing all that but
what happens is on the vice versa women
love on the conditions that you do
everything she has on this list
otherwise you get no respect back
both people are wrong just so you know
both people in today's world got it all
wrong why well first of all women are
out of their freaking mind with this
right they've been influenced by romance
you see he's saying women have been
influenced uh by romance like men have
been influenced by pornography so Women
Believe romance is something they're
entitled to when it's simply a myth
men want want their woman to be a freak
in the bedroom and experience but then
also don't want her to be experienced
so when she's super experienced he gets
intimidated he'd be like you were a hoe
and she could be a great cook she could
cook for him and clean for us he can do
everything he wants and then and then
he's like well but you were whole so
it's we live in a whole culture so the
idea that he's going to eliminate all
the women down to the no hoes is Slim
the nun well it's like rolling the dice
that's it that's what you see it's like
rolling for a guy on over 25 to find a
woman that hasn't been defiled to the
point
of um she can't parabon like that that
slim the nun he's not fighting that
woman so
maybe you need a new criteria can you
tell me about the term Alpha widows that
was something I learned that was
something I learned in the menosphere
alpha Widow
yeah that's uh the idea that a woman has
chased the top-tier man
she takes a chase the top tier men she's
had the top dogs and then once she comes
out of that and she's been spit out
because that guy has access to whoever
he wants right right and then she's been
spit out she gave her a chance she hoped
to get the NBA player I dated an NFL
player once and I thought it was gonna
work but he had 18 girlfriends in 18
cities right and so then she got spit
out now and what she's going to do is
say you have to be that guy you have to
live up to that guy's expectations and
I'll take no less please so I have I
have a theory that I've been developing
so I I feel like
I've kind of turned into a guy on my
show
because I I kind of I see firsthand what
the men go through because I recruit
from my show right right and the women
are so flaky
who knows if they're gonna show up it's
like 50 50. right it's like I can text
them the day of are you coming yeah I'm
coming well no no warning no nothing
yeah so you know what it's like to date
women right yeah so you're a bisexual
well you don't have to be in the bedroom
but by by what I said what I mean is but
I know a lot of bisexual women they have
the same complaint they have the same
complaint they're like I like women and
odd men but it's tough date women it's
tough dating women if they're the ones
that are reaching out they're flaky yeah
so now you have experienced that but you
know on this level yes and I'm like I'm
offering you guys free drinks free
podcast
and yeah and so um through this show
I've developed some theories okay
um the first being that women like being
cheated on and I'm telling you I don't
know why I've developed this I'll tell
you why I've developed this I know what
you I I don't disagree with you go ahead
because I'll interview women after woman
right right woman apps and it's like I
just noticed the same pattern right
it's like they you're gonna be well on
your way once you learn learn patterns
of human behavior yeah yeah so you guys
hate being cheated on right
we did correct right and every time so
every time when he's cheating I say did
you leave no of course not and so I'm
like okay that's weird like right you
would think you know you would think
most men would think this too yeah so
then I'm like well did so when when did
you leave right he wasn't cheating
correct and so I was like if he wasn't
cheating
then isn't that what you wanted
right and I was like do we like being
cheated on it's still it's not that you
don't it's not that you like being
cheated on what what's happening is you
realize that your man has value outside
of you right so what typically happens
is if this is gonna be the opposite if
if you find out no women like me and
we're together no woman looks the other
way nobody inquires I'm a straight loser
and you're with me you're gonna question
why you're with me
but there's no question when you're
getting cheated on that you have a man
with value so for women that guy's a top
top guy so she looks at it as that guy's
valuable at least to other women so that
makes that makes her in a sense want him
more
that's also the same as abuse victims
right they typically don't leave either
that's gonna be my next question that's
my next my next women
that's my next theory that I've
developed okay because I used to like
when girls would say they were abused or
or graped right yeah I I would just
believe them
exactly because like you know you got
that like empathy yeah and I think it's
gone now for me it's gone right so
you've been Redfield in this yes yeah
yeah because I'll ask because because
first I wouldn't really
it's because it's kind of awkward right
so they're like I was this this but then
I started to think about it and I'm like
did you press charges exactly that's
you're asking the right questions and
then they'll say no and I'll be like why
well I was too scared as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible